if i sit with a hundred dollars in my
pocket folks there is no economy
if you want to be economic you let money
flow it has to move you got people in
your company managers and executives
that are saving money they save their
money i'm like what are you doing dude
we're saving money how can you grow a
department if you go home and all you do
is save it
you know you open up somebody's freezer
and they got ice cream that's three
months old it's got this much left in
you you got you got diet coke that's
four days old it's got that much left in
it okay you got ziploc containers you
have whole cabinets of ziploc containers
and little plastic things where you in
case you had some leftover corn or peas
or potatoes you're like
don't throw it away
save that
save that that much pork chop maybe i'll
hit it tomorrow
see somebody put this back in here
that's probably elena doing that there's
no reason to put this back here it
reminds me of my mama
reminds me of when i grew up save
everything
it's a terrible product anyway why you
want to save it look at this she put two
apples in here don't put them back in
the refrigerator man
eat them or toss them
you're not gonna go broke
or get rich
saving leftovers
what are you guys doing man you got your
closet that you ain't ever gonna wear it
don't fit you it ain't fit you in in
years
right how many of you got stuff at your
house you could get rid of
you're trying to save stuff
dude how can you how can you have new
stuff come in when you're holding on to
stuff that you don't even use
right so you have to use this it only
becomes valuable when it's used
now the question is what are you going
to use it on and the other question is
why don't you use it
why are you so compelled to hold on to
it
what do y'all think that is
you know how to get more number one
reason i don't your mother did not know
how to get a new shirt that's why she
took so much put so much time and energy
in cleaning the shirt you got a stain on
okay you broke a toy your parents got
upset with you can't believe you did
that
what did what man dude
toys are to be broken
that's what a good toy is for
right
right i lost a quarter when i was eight
years old and i would have thought i
would have thought my house
was going to get torn apart because my
dad became so upset about the quarter
you're playing with money never play
with money what are you doing playing
with money and that that that lesson
pounded on me so hard it kept me from
making real money for 20 years
if you think money is scarce you hoard
it because you believe
that no more money will come to you
if you know money is abundant more money
will flow to you this isn't about being
wasteful doesn't it doesn't mean you
have to go and always empty your pockets
and buy a lot of dumb stuff and throw
away all your other stuff it doesn't
mean you have to waste your money
but it's switching the mindset of money
is not just some scarce thing that you
don't know how to make that you will
never have more of and so you need to
hoard every single dollar that you've
got
this is honestly something that i am
continuing to
rewire myself on
i struggled a lot with money especially
in the early days of my business um
even growing up i
grew up in a middle class family my
parents spent my parents are behind me
on the wall hold on there we go this is
me when i'm eight or nine and my parents
here they believed in education a lot
and they didn't have a ton of money we
weren't poor but they spent all of their
money basically on putting the three of
us kids i have two sisters through
private school
so any money that they made basically
poured into
our education
and as a result we didn't have
you know money for other things and
where my friends at these fancy schools
were getting you know bmws for their
16th birthday so they can go off and
drive
uh you know i didn't get any of that and
it's not what was me but it's more i
just had a scarce mentality around money
in my first business i was making 300
bucks a month i was eating the same bean
salad lunch every day because it would
fill me up
and wasn't very expensive
when we celebrated a win we'd go to
mcdonald's if we got a new client like
hey we sold another piece of our
software we go to mcdonald's and order a
large fries and share that between the
three of us because
it was cheap and we wanted just some
little way to celebrate and
i just remember how painful
it was to feel like you have no money
and you can't buy stuff and i couldn't
hang out with my friends
and i couldn't do what i wanted to do
and i think that has a traumatic effect
you know i mean maybe that's you as well
you you have a scarcity
mindset around money that you don't know
how to make it and so anything you've
got you've got to really hold on to it
and protect it
and again i'm not advocating for being
reckless or stupid or just throwing
money away be be smart about how you're
going to invest in user money the more
important thing is
developing the mindset that you can
create money that by bringing a lot of
value to people you can make more money
you can turn it into something
so one of the things that i've done
recently that that has helped both
myself and nina my wife is we create
what we call a care fund
and every month when we're doing our
numbers
uh nina will put together how much we've
made this month how much cash flows come
in etc and then we allocate a certain
percentage for a care fund that we have
to go off
and spend
either for ourselves or for other people
and so my default is to invest in best
invest invest invest right like invest
back into the business invest into
into into markets invest in the assets
just invest invest invest invest invest
invest
the
and that's
that's a great good mindset the downside
of that is you don't get to see
the impact that it can create
and so said you know what we need to
dedicate a percentage every month to go
and help somebody else and maybe it's
help ourselves you know um on the
weekend
nina bought a
very expensive purse
we went shopping she bought a very
offensive purse we bought a chanel bag
and
probably more expensive than she's ever
bought a bag and for me it's like oh my
gosh you can't be spending this amount
of money on a bag
but it's worth
celebrating yourself so you know what
like we earned that
we did so much work in our business you
can you can go and afford that
we've also used the money to donate the
charities we've also used the money to
support our family
and things that they needed or wanted in
their lives and
it's something that we have to spend
every month
nina asks hey can we just save it so we
can invest more and then that leads to
more in the future like no we're already
saving other money to do that like that
has to be spent every month
and so where we have to sit this might
sound crazy we have to sit down
every month and figure out how we're
going to spend this money
because my default is not to go and
spend the default is to
invest or just to save
and so doing that it doesn't have to be
a big amount of money it could it could
be a hundred bucks a month that you
force yourself to spend on making
somebody else's life better or even your
own like that thing that you would never
buy for yourself you know what i've
worked hard like i'm gonna buy or you're
gonna go buy somebody a meal or you're
gonna go and give a homeless person a
hundred dollars right like you're gonna
you're gonna do something with it
because what it does it starts to change
your mentality around it it starts to
make you feel
like more will come
that i'm creating
and so whether it's
ten bucks a hundred bucks a thousand
bucks ten thousand bucks like you know
whatever it is i'm not advocating you go
drain your bank account and just go
crazy and buy a chanel bag you know but
allocate a certain percentage every
month
so that you can start to rewire your
beliefs around money that it's not just
super scarce so that would be step
number one right allocate some kind of
budget
to helping especially others because
when you can when you help others it
just makes you feel so good and you can
help others in a lot of ways you can
help them with your time you can help
them with your expertise you can help
them you know not just give a man a fish
we teach them how to fish right but
there's there's the immediate
gratification of helping somebody
buying the coffee for the person behind
you in line or seeing somebody that you
know that that
25 bucks 100 bucks will make a big
difference and like you were able to
afford to do that
gives you the extra oomph to go off and
want to do more of it like if you know
that that 25 bucks change that person's
life imagine if you can give them
2 500 bucks
but to do that you'd have to go off and
build
a bigger business right so the the core
of your business needs to be serving and
helping and contributing back
and you can't afford yet to give
somebody 2500 bucks but you could if you
kept building your business and so it
just gives that little extra bit of
motivation incentive right to get out
there and start to do it to allocate a
certain percentage
second is to be around people who are
who are generous
be around the people who have the
mindset that you want to have if there's
a belief that you want to adopt the
fastest way to do it is to be around the
people who constantly are screaming that
belief the people who are constantly
living that belief
so
if you love
my view on something great hang around
me more often there's lots of videos you
love grant cardone's view or gary vee's
view or oprah's view on something the
more you hang around them and watch
their content and read their books and
listen to their speeches the more you're
gonna start to adopt that same belief
system
so if you want to believe that money is
not scarce then you need to be hanging
around people who believe that money is
not scarce because probably the people
in your life believe money is really
scarce
and the people that i grew up with
believe that money is really scarce the
closest people around me
and so it doesn't mean you stop hanging
out with them but you need to inject new
people in even if it's just through
youtube videos
of the people who believe the thing that
you want to believe because otherwise
you get pulled back down because your
environment has been created to keep you
where you are
so if you want to change where you are
you have to change the environment
and it used to be that you had to you
have to really change you had to go
somewhere else you had to move out you
had to find a mentor to hang out with
and have coffee with consistently now
you can do it through through youtube
i've been inspired by tons of mentors
who have never met
because of the content that i've learned
from them on youtube
but it takes the effort and intention to
be consistently around it that this is
the belief system that you want to have
you need to create that habit for
yourself from the things that are on the
wall to the clothes that you wear to the
media that you're consuming every day
being intentional with that to say this
is this this is the belief system that i
want to have i recognize i'm not there
yet but this is this belief system i
want to have and i want to be around the
people who believe this to their core
because their belief in that thing is
stronger than your belief against it
and whoever's more confident wins
and so when you're around the people who
believe that thing so much they will
pull you towards them to start having
that similar belief system and then
everything starts to change
i think having a scarcity mindset is
extremely limiting
i've i've lived through really intense
versions of it i still feel like i'm
coming out of it
i've grown a lot compared to where i
used to be but still have a lot a long
ways to go i probably still have things
that i'm holding on to that i shouldn't
uh i probably still should be more
generous than i am
um and i'm i'm working through it as
well i might just be a little bit
further ahead on the curve
definitely compared to 19 year old evan
who
thought
money was the most scarce thing in the
world
when you can
learn to make that rewiring happen
that's how you start to change your life
so if you look at the people around you
look at their beliefs especially around
money
and see what do they think and then see
where they're at in their life compared
to the people who have different beliefs
around money and where they're at who
would you rather be and you could be
there
you could be that person
if you start to change your beliefs your
environment start to
help more people with it start to allow
the money to flow
because when you start to believe that
you can create a lot more money for
yourself
a lot of things start to change
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there
you need massive massive levels of
activity going into 2021
because the other brokers remember
there's great brokers and there's
everybody else there's great agents and
everybody else you got to decide to be
in this top five percent
and do not even look at anything the
other 95 of the people do i know this is
a cruel hard message but they're not
paying me
if they were paying me i could give you
a soft loving message
okay i don't care if you guys like me or
not what i care about is whether you
like
whether you like you or not more at the
end of this year
than you did at the beginning of the
year because that's the target man i got
to love myself i got to like me
okay i'm not trying to produce for the
rest of the world i'm trying to produce
for me i'm not even trying to produce
for my kids and my wife
yeah they're beneficiaries
but look if i can please me
if i can hit my if i could shock myself
okay would i be able to take care of my
wife and kids
my kids man they're lucky to be alone
for the ride
little freeloaders i think that there's
a shortage of real men on this planet i
think most men are
i mean frankly just [ __ ]
you know i don't know if your audience
can handle that word but
look man if you can't get your money
right
something's wrong
if you can't take care of your family
you got to ask yourself how much of a
man are you like for me that identifies
me as a man my ability to take care of
my family i don't just mean financially
but i do mean financially right
my job as a
as head of household
is to take care of the economics of the
household you know the word economy if
you look it up in the dictionary it
comes from managing the household it had
nothing to do with the business
it was about managing the household so
if you go back a thousand years we've
been managing households my job as a man
is to provide a place where it's warm
a place where we can sleep a place where
we're protected place where there's food
right not money right i need to be able
to take care of the family shelter food
clothing
and i need to have some fun my family
wants to have fun we want to have
experiences so i need to provide a
secure environment for them so they're
not think bad things aren't just
happening and so so men need to like
bone up man like the government can't
take care of you
bone up you know this yeah bone up get
strong right right
so get a get a backbone
and take care of your family and quit
blaming the government
are
making excuses that your neighbor or
the economy or whatever conditions look
i've had some terrible conditions in my
life
uh from the age of uh 15 till
25 it was awful for me
10 years nobody would want to go through
the 10 years
that i went through do some people have
it worse than i did probably but i don't
want to do those 10 those 10 years were
terrible for me as degrading as a human
being can experience
drugs yeah drugs but mostly just so many
bad choices so many bad people
you know so so much self
self
deprivation and
and just a lack of self-esteem and
self-love
for myself because of a lot of bad
choices
so i understand what goes on through for
a person when they're making bad choices
and and and people just need to man up
you know bone up the women need to do
the same thing by the way yeah women
they are stronger than men today
oh
look i hate pain any kind of pain women
can handle ten times the pain i can
handle my job is to get eight billion
people to know me if enough people know
me they'll buy from me how many believe
that
i'm not going to be i'm not going to be
a slave to one person or one vertical or
one niche or one partnership i have you
guys have the whole world at your access
the whole world and by the way if you
can't get south korea to talk about you
you can't get south indiana
or indianapolis to talk about you
there's people in korea that are tied to
hawaii that are tied to colombia that
know somebody in indiana and it can just
bang out like that
and i also believe that if i could get
enough people to know me in one market i
think that there's something that
actually happens
i think if you could out
if you could get if you could push out
enough frequency about your brand
yourself your ideas to enough people
that you hit some critical mass i don't
know if any of you agree with this but i
think there's a spiritual component to
where if you can vibrate through enough
all of a sudden other people start
thinking i know that dude
i've said this for years if i can get
enough people a very small percentage of
the population to know me i think the
other 99 become convinced they know me
um do you think that somebody needs to
reach a certain like status before but
no no no you do not need to reach
certain status you need to assume the
status now you need to have the altitude
right now to be the professional that
says hey i know about fitness
i know about plumbing i know about
trucks just take whatever you guys are
certain about and post out of it and by
the way if you're not certain about it
write an article about what your
uncertainty's costing you you're going
to figure out every possible angle but
none of that's going to happen until you
guys make a decision to blow up
and none of the blow up gonna happen
until you make a decision that money is
important because if you got people
around you saying money's not important
ain't no way you're gonna do this stuff
because it hurts
when nobody sees your stuff
number three number three study two
multi-millionaires do not
take heed to this do not study a
millionaire once a person becomes a
millionaire the first thing they do
unfortunately is going to conservation
to protect the million study
multi-millionaires study people that
have consistently developed and proven
because the tens or twenties or thirties
or hundreds of millions of dollars that
they've accumulated that they have the
right practice the right discipline and
they're still expanding you don't need
22 mentors study two people deep
that have gotten it right study two
people so deep rather than 20 people
shallow i promise you'll make a
difference if you get a chance to spend
three days with anybody that's
accumulated 30 40 50 100 million dollars
i'll promise you it's a game changer so
put that on your bucket list i'm gonna
spend three days with a
multi-millionaire in an environment
where i can learn from them it will be a
game changer for you and also limit your
study to two people not 22 people that
will create you from having conflictive
uh data and content and information
nobody's ever done it by themselves
so the old the the entrepreneur that's
uh popular right now is the guy that
works from home
he's a solopreneur
um i don't know if you have this term we
have yeah yeah it's a complete misnomer
nobody is ever existed on this planet
and done something successful by
themselves
no it's never happened
so there's no there's zero examples of
anybody that's done any i mean jesus had
had 12 of course had 12 guys he was
rolling with right alexander the great
had an army uh genghis khan
had had like you're not doing this thing
by yourself nobody does like for too
long i ran by myself
and and it took a lot of energy you know
it took a lot of energy it takes more
energy running by yourself
uh ryan secco here the captain the pilot
and and the real estate dude he always
says dude it's just more fun to run with
the team and he's right yeah you know
henry ford people said henry ford made
the car out of his garage he said yeah
but the company didn't make
they didn't make
to the
yeah yeah so uh mark zuckerberg said you
know facebook was made out of a dorm
facebook was made when he moved to
silicon valley and started a company
uh steve jobs steve and and the the
other dude what was the dude
yeah yeah they built apple you know
supposedly built it out of their garage
yeah nobody knew about apple until he
moved the company
and started
and added employees so nobody's doing
anything great by themselves you guys
would take days off it's my day off you
ain't entitled to a day off
[Music]
why do you think you should have
wednesdays off or thursdays or or you
can't work saturdays or
sunday sunday you can't work on a sunday
okay are you and you got people around
you telling you not to work on sunday we
have to have a little life balance dude
how can you have life balance when you
broke
how can you have life balance at a
holiday inn when the people next door
keep you up all night
that ain't life balance that's not even
a vacation
right the whole trip how many have been
on the trip you did the budget trip
included the free breakfast
you did it on miles
and you wish you didn't even go how many
been on that trip before
maybe you don't do the trip maybe you're
not entitled to a trip this year maybe
you're not ready to trip
that's what elena and i did for 10 years
the sacrifice the sacrifice today we'll
sacrifice this week we'll sacrifice this
month we'll sacrifice this year we'll
sacrifice
so one day maybe we don't have to
compromise
every week we talk about our finances
what do we do this week how much do we
make where are we going what are we
spending okay the moment i say hey no
more jackets no more
stop it she'll stop it
so that we can one day we can one day
spend whatever we want okay there there
is should come a time where you guys
should be able to spend whatever you
want but most people are spending what
they can afford
now
only to find out later they can never
have anything they don't understand how
to make their money multiply and most
people don't understand there is a
sacrifice phase
we went through the sacrifice phase
where there was years of just cut off
everything and we weren't saving for a
landing
for the rainbow that's right y'all need
to save for the rainbow you need to you
see we didn't go on a vacation for 13
years yeah i've been saving for this
stuff i did i wasn't saving for
vacations i was saving so i could bank
into real estate so i could go to sleep
at night
and even if i had a bad night of sleep
and had to get up three or four times
i'm like dang i'm making money in my
sleep even if i'm unhappy i'm like i'm
making money in my sleep man see that's
the goal that you and your wife need to
have let's make money when we go to
turks and caicos or when we go to st
bart's or when we go to cali let's go
waste some money later in our life maybe
you say hey i'm going to sacrifice
today
so i don't have to compromise in the
future
i'm 20 years old in contracting here in
michigan um my biggest question is
you know gain credibility in business
being young in an industry yeah so good
question i'm glad you said new to the
industry not because you're only 20
years old
you got it you got to get you got to
become you got to become the uh the
expert buddy i don't i don't know how to
tell you this any other way you got to
become you got to become the expert in
the room you got to know more than
everybody else you got to be like people
say oh if you're in if you're in a room
and you're the smartest guy in the room
you're in the wrong room you go in a
room dude you need to be the smartest
guy in the room
you need to be the guy in the room that
sucks the oxygen out of the room
so elon
elon musk walks in a room and
everybody's like going up to the office
but doing my best just trying to build
report and uh no no don't don't don't
try to build rapport dude you got you
got to become an expert at your deal
like if you're milking cows you need to
become the freaking guy that knows every
freaking angle on a on a cows
okay
like
michigan
right gosh
okay so dude take take like like
you're 20 years old bro spend the next
four or five years becoming an expert in
your field
study it breathe it
live in it don't drink the kool-aid
do backstrokes in it i don't do
businesses that don't serve my life
so the real estate
it's just what i'm doing every day right
it's the speaking
it it just all fits for me
so i need a lot of action but they all
work like like my hand i move my pinky
and all the other fingers removed so if
i move this business it it touches these
businesses the businesses are all
connected they're interconnected well
they're a bit connected right so if i
move one
we came here to do a speaking gig okay
but we stacked this interview this is
part of my business right my our online
presence is dependent upon me being
willing to do this in addition we don't
go any place for one thing
so the guy that tells you focus on one
business we do why don't we have one
finger
why don't i just have one thing great
right
boom i got i got noticed i got five
fingers and i got two hands
i had a i had a girlfriend but this was
before i was married she says you want
your cake and you want to eat it too and
i said yeah
why have a cake
if you can't eat it okay so my my mom
used to tell me you need to focus on one
thing at a time i'm like five fingers
five feet two hands
okay so i i want my hands and all a
bunch of pies
i just want to be sure i want to eat
that pie okay i want to eat that meal
right because i think a lot of people
have their hands
sorry i think a lot of people have their
hands and stuff they don't really want
to eat the meal do you guys just
rubberneck your whole life you know you
ever been driving down the road there's
a wreck on the side and everybody's like
oh my god why is all the traffic stopped
there's only one person with a flat tire
on the side of the road right
everybody's stopping to see what the
hell happened over there
you rub a neck in your life and not
getting where you want to go okay
because everything's a distraction some
people call it schizophrenia like my
friend kathleen but it's not really
schizophrenia it's a lack of focus
number nine
make hard decisions fast people say man
you're a hard man you're a tough dude
okay look you got to make hard decisions
fast when things get tough they say the
tough get going truth is when things get
tough
the successful make hard decisions
quickly that's why super successful
people are often misunderstood they're
willing to make hard decisions
that often don't make them look good and
for which they're later judged the truth
is for you to be financially successful
you will have to make very very
difficult decisions when you do
make them fast my mom used to say if
you're walking through hell son
pick it up go fast i want you to walk
away
understanding that some of you have
businesses
that are just not good businesses
[Music]
and if you have a business that's no
good you can't build the empire you want
why do i need money what don't i know
about money why are people struggling
with money you should ask yourself these
questions why are you coming up short
on money
is it what you know or what you don't
know
how many of you know this saying
knowledge is
okay how many of you agree with that
how many agree knowledge is power so
look if you don't have money and you
have knowledge maybe you have the wrong
knowledge
i hated sales i hated it
five i was in five sales jobs
was a disaster at all of them
i hated absolutely
um because hated
the master of sales i i am i embrace the
things i hate why why were you bad at it
why did you hate it i didn't know well i
was bad at it because nobody teaches
anybody how to be good at sales
you know so
i didn't know how to communicate to
people i didn't know how to shake your
hand didn't know how to build rapport
i'm i'm
i'm honest enough that i'm not going to
lie to people so the stuff i was being
taught to do i didn't like
you know they ask a question you ask
them a question the place where i was
working they took me back and i just i
threw myself into it and it's
interesting when you commit to something
little gifts
just start automatically showing up it's
a phenomenal thing
so so i threw my a guy walks up he gives
me an uh it was a little cassette tape
he's like hey i heard this i thought you
might like it
i've been here five years you guys don't
know me you know why
i didn't let you know me if you don't
know me you won't flow me right or wrong
so my job is to make sure i'm known
today today it's easier than it's ever
been before that's why i'm a guy that's
using
social media to get known takes courage
to stand up here it takes courage to get
known it takes courage to build a brand
it takes courage to build a youtube
channel and an instagram and a facebook
i'm 60 years old i don't know anything
about instagram except that i got 900
000 people that follow me every day like
a religion
you ask what church they go to i go to
the church of grant cardone
okay what's my name
my name is grant cardone what's my name
my name cause you didn't know this is
for the people that didn't know my name
is
grant cardone let me hear it
okay my job my job my first job your
first job is to make sure people know
your damn name because if they don't
know your name they i don't care what
you sell you're a nurse you work at
mcdonald's you're a bellman i don't care
what you do you're parking cars it don't
matter if i don't know who you are
it doesn't matter how good you are how
how clean you are okay it doesn't matter
your values don't matter nothing matters
if i don't know you so don't believe in
this concept about balancing business in
life i've never all the people that talk
about it yeah don't have don't have the
very thing they're trying to get
probably yeah so you're constantly
balancing something you understand that
i think so totally totally so so if you
just like what i do is i just push into
everything
right i push into everything as hard as
i can
and and again the goal is life it's not
the business
it's my life right business is part of
my life
so having fun is part of my life my
spiritual part is part of my life so i'm
going to push everything into that thing
that i'm working on the 10x the 10x
thing was about i'm pushing
like if if it's if it's in the business
i'm going to push as hard as i can on
that
and my kids are with me my wife's with
me she they're with me so they're
they're having the experience of this
push
then we turn around we push over here oh
we want to help charities out and we
push 10x
into that direction well it's just exp
it just blows out the edges
of the life right so that we get to have
a bigger experience as opposed to okay
now i need to
put this here
and manage this part right now
which means when i'm doing this when i'm
finding time just for my kids i'm
abandoning all these other things and my
life gets smaller all the commitment
stuff oh you got to be committed oh you
got to be committed we're always talking
to my trainer about this you got to be
committed yeah treat this there's only
one thing you really have to do
because the commitment's not going to
come until you do this other thing
the thing that has got me through
everything
got me to where i'm at today the thing
that changed everything was me just
taking action
just doing it i mean i know that's that
old nike saying right just do it
man even if you don't feel like it even
if you're not committed even if you're
not getting any gains
even if you're not winning i talk about
this in the rules of success
show up
just take action make the call
knock on the door
send out the email
bug people if you have to you know until
you get good and it doesn't sound like
bugging anymore it's just the
professional knows how to bug people
without bugging them
so look
just take action even if you don't feel
like it money is so simple
okay anybody got a 100 bill
give me a hundred dollars sir
give this man a big hand for having some
money
okay
i just had an idea i said i wonder [ __ ]
i ain't got any money on
i had an idea now i'm going to teach you
a lesson right now that'll make you rich
if you freaking get it okay number one
i want some money
[Laughter]
number two
i need to ask somebody if they got a
hundred
number three
i need to get the money
it's no more complicated than that
i didn't go manufacture something i
didn't build a business plan
i didn't create a product i had an idea
the the the length of time between your
idea and the money will determine
whether or not you're successful
the length of time
between the idea
and the monetization big word for
get the money
the the distance between the idea and
the money
will determine whether you take off or
not why why do we make so many excuses i
think that we are like excuses making
machines
yeah yeah like if i miss a deal we we do
a lot of real estate deals so if i miss
a deal i'm always going to what did i do
wrong in that deal first response for me
is what did i do wrong in that deal that
they didn't pick me
what did i do wrong that i didn't get
that deal what did we do wrong that we
didn't hit our number there like i'm
never saying it's not blaming somebody
well i don't have control when i blame
i want control
so
even if they are to blame right
i want control i'm not gonna assign you
blame
if you hit my car i'm gonna i'm gonna
say what did i do wrong
what did i do
that allowed you to hit my car
i did something
so even in the most dumb dumb like i i
ended up in a lawsuit where a guy
basically
found something
sued me for it
i didn't do anything to this dude
my immediate response was what did i do
to create that frivolous
situation he was a criminal total
criminal sued me for 60 million bucks
he just sued me because he he thought he
could get something from it but but i
did something and the reason i want to
assume that
what the cause i want to be the cause
point is because if i assume that
position even though i didn't really do
anything
um
then i can control what i did i can't
control what another person does but i
can spend time and energy controlling
what i do the company is only as great
as the driver is number two
does the dude have a bunch of fuel you
know what fuel is see this plane right
here this plane's no good no matter how
good this plane is if there's no fuel
play no good
plane don't go anyplace without fuel
neither does a company i know guys that
have great companies but they're out of
fuel
they're just not
they're not going to use it they're
drivers they were drivers they used to
drive they got fuel in a tank but three
they won't use it they're not going to
press because somebody's on their neck
right now saying conserve your money a
lot of rich people this happens to a lot
of rich people people get rich they go
from the middle to rich and never get
wealthy and when the wealthy it becomes
impossible to get wealthy like the
rockefellers or the people that were
talking about the duponts the morgans
the uh who the vanderbilts because
because the cardinal the cod don'ts
because they get satisfied with wealthy
i'm sorry with rich and they never get
wealthy wealthy is
generational money grant died i
guarantee you my grandkids will be
talking about me that's a bam
right there dude
that dude that dude
that dude god damn
okay
and then number four dude you got to
have a future like the future i'm
interested in and and by the way i'm
gonna go back to the new world order
boys and girls the the illuminati the
masons whoever they are
these people think about futures you
guys don't they're thinking about
generations that's what the japanese do
the japanese they think about future
generations they're not thinking about
right now how about the muslims they're
thinking about
lifetimes from now how many heard this
before people buy from people they like
no no no people buy from people they
know okay if you're taking notes people
buy from people they know period they
don't buy the best product they don't
buy the cheapest product people buy from
people they know
because if you don't know me
trust will not happen
that's why i rolled up on damon and said
hey how about i put you in the plane and
i fly you to provide you to vegas same
dude's telling me i was stupid behind a
plane
i said dude come on
what's wrong with you man you spent too
much time on a street corner selling
hats
that bird that bird that bird is what
got me in front of you dj little man
oh yeah yeah you're right man
and then he says now i'd have gone with
you anyway you would not have got on
jetblue with me
don't lie man i know you're the people
shark but don't lie what am i call you
up hey damon i bought a ticket for us on
southwest
you want to fly to vegas with me and we
can eat peanuts
he wouldn't have gone with me how many
agree he would not have gone with me
come on man he might be the people's job
but he ain't stupid he's like hey i
ain't doing that
right or wrong
he said to me what's the fuel in that
jet cost i said bro you you're thinking
small bro
he's like what do you mean what's it
cost what's the damn fuel in the jet
cost
i said i don't know
why don't you know i said because the
jet
ain't no good without fuel
well i think the the idea of
knocking on doors
you know
talking to people yeah like these are
the skills that are not taught in the
schools this is what goes back to your
question about the school system failing
the
the the required skills
i need a client like if you simplify the
thing that people like about what we do
is we simplify the business process
i need to make a contact
how can i do that
like how can i just simply
if i'm doing if i'm a cameraman and i
want more work you know how do i
knock on a door or make a phone call get
in front of someone
so hard impress them
you know if i go to heron's right here
i'll see how many people don't have that
skill i walk in that i don't even get
hello
you know i don't get hello how you doing
great to have you here appreciate you
being here it's so nice for you to drop
by thanks for coming into cartier i mean
it's a three million dollar ring over
there i went in there the other day i
can't even get anybody to show me
anything
i'm like how much is the ring
you know they kind of look at me right
can you show it to me do you mind
showing it to me
he showed it to me told me how much it
was and i leave you didn't show me a
second ring a third ring or fourth ring
so those are the skills that people need
right how do i
how do i interact with people
communicate yeah the middle class adds
and subtracts
and and clearly the middle class never
figured out
how to do what the super wealthy do like
it's almost like
hundreds of millions of people in
america stop math at adding and
subtracting and never got to the
multiplication part
because the super wealthy are
multipliers oh by the way time
energy and money they multiply all of
them they're like like i have time i
want to make more time how do i do that
you learned how to add you learned how
to subtract but that's not what the ross
charles did that's not what the
rockefellers did that's not what the
duponts did
they multipliers
they're multipliers
this
by the way 10x
is
a gateway drug to the illuminati
i'm telling you right now the 10x was
basically a secret kind of passage
for all of you that want the new world
order for all of you interested in the
invisible rich for the masons out there
that you're like i know there's 13
families i know there's a deal with the
federal reserve i know there's world
monarchs don't you know that 10x the 10x
rule don't you guys know the 10x rule is
actually the front door
to this secret society to the invisible
rich how did you get into the training
business
uh i i had a passion for for helping
people when i was a young salesperson
and um
i
found that when i had struggles
when i had
droughts
cold spells where i wasn't selling
anything if i would help if i would help
somebody else it it always broke my
drought
so
for some reason it was easier when i
wasn't doing well to help somebody else
to help someone else and it and it
seemed to break my it's i don't know why
i worked like that but maybe it's one of
those golden rules about help people you
know the more you give the more you get
and so it always broke this cold moment
i had
when i would reach out and help another
person i was 28 years old three years
sober no drugs in my body for three
years i'm selling cars i'm moving
toyotas
and i'm getting good at it too like you
come in and say look i got bad credit
and i'm not buying today i'm like oh
that's two cars
[Music]
i'm a penalized i'm gonna penalize you
for saying that
okay
okay
yeah bad you got bad credit that's
perfect
at least you got some credit
see i ain't positive i'm there to get
something so so captain ryan says to me
he's like you're the most positive
person i know i said dude i'm not
positive at all
i'm 10x
[Music]
i get results
okay i want to get the deal done i want
to make my kids proud of me
my kids aren't going to remember whether
i was positive or not they're going to
remember whether daddy delivered the
goodies or not
you understand when you go to whole
foods and they say that'll be 427.
for three bags
and you're like
i got a good attitude
[Music]
they'd be like you need to get some 10x
you need to get some 10x's and money to
go with your freaking attitude
all the greats on this planet were
addicted to something jesus was addicted
he's like hey man i'm going to do
whatever it takes
right or wrong
okay you got to get addicted to
something good all addictions are not
created equal
okay i'm addicted to my wife
i'm addicted to my kids
i'm addicted to my purpose
i'm addicted to helping out i'm addicted
to making a difference i'm addicted to
doing whatever it takes
to show and be an example of the
blessings that i have one of the things
that we do a little trick we do at our
company
is we always have something on our
calendar to look forward to okay if you
want to stay motivated today's what
sunday
i always have something out here out
here out here out here and out here to
look forward to little short runways
that keep me excited okay i'm going to
turks and caicos to shoot a real estate
program when i leave here
yesterday i walked out of here i'm
freaking exhausted i'm like boy i can't
wait to get to turks and caicos see it
re-energizes me
right now when i'm done with that i need
something else to look forward to here i
got a whole bunch of stuff that's going
to happen here at the end of the month
that is going to keep me jacked up when
i'm at turks and caicos because the
truth is turks and caicos could get a
little boring for a guy like me
how many of you have trouble going on
vacations you have trouble unwinding
okay you don't even want to go you're
like i can't even enjoy this
so i need little tricks i have little
tricks everybody should do this in their
life okay you need things to look
forward to the world you live in today
the cnbc and the cnn and the netflix
be happy
just be happy
be satisfied with what you have
there's no push man
there's nobody pushing you
how about this you can do more how many
of you can do
more oh my god if that's all you got how
many of you can do more
oh god damn if you know you can do more
if you know you can do more
then you have to do more
if you know you can help if you know you
can make a difference if you don't
you're going to have this freaking big
big hole inside of you no no amount of
money can fill this thing up
so fill it up for 30 years since i left
that treatment center i have been doing
one thing studying business
i don't need to worry about my neighbor
i don't need to worry about trump i
don't need to worry about obama i don't
need to worry about the democrats i
don't need to worry about anything until
i worry about these 36 inches
man man people like hey do you believe
in aliens dude i got i'm having trouble
with this
all i'm trying to do is expand it over
to here
once i do that maybe i can expand a
little bit but i got to get those six
feet under control
i don't criticize other people i'm too
busy criticizing me
while i work on my life i hope other
people hate on me and criticize me i
love it
it's fuel man i'm like then come on
bring it on
the number one reason you will fail in
this 10x thing
the number one reason businesses fail
is the inability
the inability to sell products in
quantities great enough
and at margins high enough that is the
only reason
you will fail you take too long to go
from the idea
to sell on enough products
volume at margins high enough
do that learn to do that
and you can make any dream a reality
okay i want to help the world
this is not taught in schools there's
eight billion people on this planet and
there's no shortage of information how
many have heard this before knowledge is
power
then why are so many people suffering
why are so many people suffering
no they ain't stupid man we have more
information available to us today than
at any time in the history of the world
we got too much information at this
point you got too much information and
not enough action 25 years old i'm
selling automobiles i'm broke i'm in
debt forty thousand dollars in debt
spiritually bankrupt physically bankrupt
hate myself
only thing i had
was an opportunity
the car dealer that i worked for took me
back that was an opportunity
don't
dismiss
the opportunity
you can't go anyplace
without an opportunity no matter how
talented you are no matter how gifted
you are no matter what god has done for
you without an opportunity you will not
move from your garage
your life cannot improve without an
opportunity it's impossible
you guys don't like sales because you
ain't got any courage
that's why you want to be a you want to
be the vice president of something
that's why you guys want to call it
something else okay most of you in the
room don't even have sales on your card
you you sell real estate for re max okay
or keller and you don't even have sales
on the card you're in network marketing
you refused we don't do sales here
what do you do then okay what do you do
i mean
i think the company's got a financial
statement
you ever read a financial statement
what's the first line on a financial
statement
huh
what's that first line it's the first
line by the way okay i've seen a bunch
of income statements in my life the
first the first ones are like two to
maybe max four inches long big companies
big giant companies okay i got five
companies they run to one financial
statement and the top line the top line
the sales line you could call it i think
it's called also what revenue
could be called gross revenue
okay you know people are getting
confused now
okay they start getting away from this
word some some some college guy i came
in and said we can't call it sales man
we got to call something like at least
two or three words
i mean i went to harvard
it's not about how much money you make
folks
can you use money
can you use it okay look this top these
top lines right here are about income
if you hate sales
you hate income i don't care who you are
i don't care what your age is okay i
spent the first from the age of 25 years
old to 45 years old i spent 20 years
thinking small thinking small
and taking too long i built three little
businesses they were all doing good man
they were doing good three of them man
from scratch first little business i was
a millionaire when i was 30 33 years old
punching shoving hard work man the more
money i had the more scared i was
because i had just enough money
to be scared
as soon as you get a million dollars
you're going to go into terror
i'm telling you you can be like
what am i going to do now
okay i wasn't scared before now i got
something to lose
that's why you never want to get your
advice from a millionaire if you're
taking notes never get your advice from
a millionaire ever
okay this held me down for 20 years
20 years it held me down you're looking
at me like huh i read the millionaire
next door
what did the millionaire next door say
buy a used truck and don't go to
starbucks
you say four bucks a day for the next 38
years you're gonna be in heaven no you
ain't you're gonna be stupid it's dumb
man okay if four dollars is going to
break you on any given day you're just
back to thinking the way you were
thinking when you didn't have anything
buy everything on sale okay everything
you're going to buy is going to be on
sale you got to get a deal every time
you buy something is that what your
daddy taught you never pay retail for
anything that means nobody will ever pay
you retail folks when i was 23 years old
i was beaten within
inches of my life i had 76 stitches put
in my head and face
because i had made nine years of bad
choices
my dad died when i was 10 years old
i think that there's an epidemic in this
country where where families are missing
a father
i know for me i was a good kid i grew up
in a middle class family my mom and my
dad were very responsible hard-working
people
i didn't get beat up there was no
alcoholism there was no drug addiction i
did not get brought up the way kanye
west did
kanye's got excuses i didn't have any
and there's a whole bunch of kids in
america that don't have any excuses but
they don't have
a purpose they don't have an opportunity
and they don't have anything to do
and that was me
when my dad died i was 10 years old and
from 10 to 16 when i should have been
experiencing grief
you know and and and
i was angry about it how many of you had
a loss before and you got angry about it
customer doesn't buy from you guy
doesn't show up you get angry
angry is not a response to the situation
then when somebody sits on anger for
long enough what happens is without a
purpose without a purpose an individual
is gonna go array
no matter how good they are they're
gonna go off and do other things
and so by the time i was 16 years old i
had a drug problem but by the time i was
20 years old i was using drugs every
single day and by the time i was 23 i
was carrying a gun
every day
worried i was going to get killed every
day had a college degree
17 years of spending school the more mo
the more college i got the less money i
had and the more trouble i ended up in
okay 23 years old i get beat i'm in a
hospital my mom comes to the hospital
she looks at me and says but where's my
son
okay that was me not too long ago it
doesn't seem like it was that long ago
and today legalshield has me to speak to
you today
[Applause]
i i tell you that to tell you like
anybody can come back i don't care how
old you are how young you are what color
you are what your problems are anybody
can come back if you want more
inspiration morning videos they're not
on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel just for it it's right
there next to me go click it there
continue to believe and i'll see you
there